threads and everything bro got whole
story's in the whole nine
but here we go
oh yeah this is man infinite azure this
is first to three first to three for
this last set on the loser side of
things to see who's gonna make it to
grand finals here we go
oh there's that four four three gets the
back three just to get the combo too
takes the op
oh
that's the one electric bro
nice block nice standing four
again x-men trying to get around him but
he just has that nice hook fist man it's
hard to get around
damn corpse bashing bro
[Music]
wow nice [ __ ] out of the roll
combo does get scaled a lot and it
wasn't like a finish but still
[Music]
that means getting that pressure doesn't
give a damn
okay a little bit defensive from uh
natural
gets hit he rolls out of that okay
returns to pressure
i like that option
to stay on the ground too
yeah yeah that's smart smart
oh well
this could be a brain no i was knocking
a brain i'm like this is saying
something i'm not
nah
yeah fishing right there trying to find
something big
the lows starting to add up once again
back turn aop scoring a lot of hits oh
whoa
[Music]
oh
just maintaining his buttons
making the conversions
and actually tried to make that count
with the back three
pop kick
that's just the startup of aop is that
what happened he just did it
merry moment right there hey
bruh
oh my god
bro that hit right on the beat that was
sick
uh we do that's how we do it here dude
with tis you know i see
nice nice even if you check my magic
wall that
taking that first one pretty solid
pretty solid um look
extra mint tried to fight back he got up
he got one piece but not enough not
enough
i think that like naturals on a tear
like he's the past few matches we've
seen he knocked dion gray he knocked a
friendly tree he knocked wowzer like god
give the guy this medal man he already
like won three finals already just to
get here it's like okay okay relax you
know now he's just still going at it so
it's pretty good to see him like
maintain pace huh
and it seems like natural is really
starting to pick up pace like it's
really starting to become like a
snowball kind of effect where like even
though he's not doing like these crazy
instances he's not getting like a crazy
amount of damage but just keeping that
momentum in his favor especially versus
a character like xiao yu who is known
wants to start feeling once she starts
feeling herself if you're a player and
you're feeling yourself with xiaoyu you
really start to go crazy with the
offense with the buttons not to the
point where you're going to get launched
or anything there it is we did see the
hop kick workout but not so much
especially now that we're getting a
complete character switch with the lily
oh yeah that's his tgo like despite uh
xiaoyu being his main he's been popping
the lily recently and he's getting mad
results and you know all and also
getting our tgo rank which is really
hard in oc which is a smaller region but
it's hard to get as many matches to get
that you know only billion of matches
you have to get to get that rank so yeah
they managed to pull it off with a lily
yeah yeah
and we talked about the size of the
buildings in the world right oh yeah
that's bad
100 100 yeah yeah
so the matchup knowledge is being tested
but you know
i feel like everyone at this level
already does know it like you know
to be a player of this caliber you kind
of know your matchups at this point well
i heard the electric didn't see it
though
i don't know man he's
oh yeah
okay how's it gonna close in okay a
little kick
there's another one oh goes for the
triple no good it's the low power you
should carry him to the wall right now
pretty comfortably
oh does not stick okay
oh wow extra man oh
and close it with a rager beautiful
[Music]
[ __ ] now he's gonna sit and watch that
yep
round three give him something to think
about natural ties up the second game
one round gets the back three but no
combo
oh big counter
good carry lily has very good carry not
only are the side steps something you
need to be worried about but her wall
carry if she actually gets a launcher
oh okay
god the side will save lives man
oh my god
bumping him out round four damn
fight
okay this is extra missed chance okay
duck's there the hulk fist doesn't get a
chance to punish it
down oh counter
takes the okie i like that in the open
stage just take the okie that way you
get to keep the pressure wait a minute
though not able to make anything happen
from that big launcher
extra man with the lily actually has the
round lead and the life lead
oh you're dead
bringing it back
times up the set and losers final one
game of peace
that is clean that is very clean look at
that man extra mint he's he's got it man
he knows what's up so that that was very
good that was very good but now this
seems to be a more interesting match
before i was feeling like
this could be like potentially like a
natural could have just produced a
blowout and just get all three but now
it's coming back and forth and then lily
pick bang it worked i was like okay i'm
listening i'm listening like he could
hold that character for the whole match
at this point yeah
were you expecting like the switch to
lily
uh a little bit i was like okay if he's
gonna make a change it's now or never at
this point because the first three match
he has to like pull it out like i knew
that he had a pocket lily because he
depends sometimes he'll turn up to a
tournament just with lily and that's it
and he'll still get you know top places
so you know but
usually the pattern is like if it's
serious if he's really going for it the
xiao you is what usually dominates
that's why i was not you know shocked
when he pulled that out okay he's going
all in but now it looks like he's xiaoyu
has been not serving him properly in
these matchups why not try the lily at
this point you know he's got the skills
and it's working out for him so yeah
let's give it a go
all right still in a race to see who's
gonna get back to this grand finals from
loser's side
twilight conflict
oh
we're doing general outpost or
hey jungle outfits let's go oh my bad
that's it twilight conflict geez my bad
oh that's all right that was so good man
so good
get off the hands
nice stop you stepping wow nice electric
i was cleaning one okay the thunder hook
fist okay
there will be counting four four
fix him at the wall
trying to keep him in place
look at that don't be ducking that
oh he tries to catch up with the
standing forward
seems like he's in naturals head right
now
against the wall while standing four
two four and the balcony break back turn
come on
let's go
back through combos
damn okay okay natural on the way to
take a lead now starting strong with the
hook fist
to get the wall pretty comfortably right
in the corner actually even better for
himself can can not
yeah keeping him in check trying to
prevent her from like lateral movement
that's all right
i'm not breaking yeah
okay
okay who's gonna approach the first
going with that health sweep yeah
oh
natural slowing the pace of that last
round was down to a crawl and then you
saw guy really like picky with some of
the options he started to go for
especially on block seeing how like
reactionary that lily was playing right
there and knows that she can sidestep
super well so i like just the jabs check
to see if there was going to be a side
step that's one of the reasons that the
matterhorn didn't hit right didn't get
anything big from yeah but that would
have been the round and that could have
been something else you would have had
that would have been another round you
would have had the win to get that match
so i like playing slowing it down a
little bit jab check with the side step
to see if anything's going to happen
didn't get the punish once again but
just the fact that you was able to bait
it out let you know that you're on the
right thought process with the meta
but yeah dude this is looking very
interesting now now let's make or break
for extra mint it did so well to get
through to with a side and now it's he's
risking losing it all you know again
third place ain't bad i ain't gonna lie
so
but you know you want the you know what
the big w dude yeah you're messing
around going with a little mishima dojo
interesting pick well actually a good
it's a pretty solid pick to be honest
let's see has once again great wall
carry and just the fact that now you're
committed to you no matter what win or
lose if you win this round you're still
stuck with lilly you still can't switch
anyway yeah so you've committed yeah
oh the root of all evil
oh yeah
keeping him in place
it's a solid round start right now
massive health lead
four four actually four four three
wow
wow
holy moly okay
electric you know what's coming that was
the warning
i'm standing for
oh there it is
getting the wall splat
how's going to keep him in place
wow natural going deep right now going
deep into the move list
the mental alertness one plus two gets
the launch this is set point your extra
mint needs something big right now needs
this round to begin with can't actually
lose any more rounds at this point or
you're out of here get this match you
got one more game to play but
oh counter here damn this counter hits
yeah there's
no mercy yeah naturals ability to keep
extreme in place is really strong
despite wow
you've got to be kidding me
no round brown to close it off
whoa ow this guy
that yeah imagine going out like that
rip dude that was insane
dude natural
killing it
moving into the grand final his chance
to actually
get the first spot because he didn't
make it through a winner's side top
eight so now he's now he isn't winning
side top eight who would have thought
well so now all he needs to get that
reset
so an extra min of course killer
performance made it all the way to third
place